foreign
is kicking us off this hour in
Charleston South Carolina Marty welcome
to the show
hey thanks for having me absolutely how
can John and I help
um I have a question it's a time for me
to get back into the real world um with
a job and I'm curious what might be
better for me
um to go after a state or local
government job with less pay and more
benefits or go back to a private sector
to where I maybe make more wages but
might have to pay a little bit more as
far as the benefits go
where have you been
um I own a small business that didn't
take off as well as I had planned very
cool so you got in the ring you took a
couple of swings and you got knocked
down and so now you're like all right I
I fought that dude and he's pretty tough
and so I'm gonna go get another job
yeah it's something like that good for
you man I started a small business with
my buddy um in August and he ended up
passing away in October ah dude I'm so
sorry man so you got you got uh grief on
top of grief man
yeah it's it's been a struggle for sure
um how old are you my wife I'm 34. okay
what about your wife my wife and I have
been um we've been um we've been praying
on it um the whole time because I had a
decent job
um at a construction company as a diesel
mechanic
um and my buddy was like hey man I want
to try going out on my own um would you
come and work with me and I was like
sure I'll give it a shot with you and uh
I was about ready to uh pull the plug on
that because things weren't going very
well for us
um and like I said he passed away in
October and
um two or three days after he passed
away we had got
um a large
um check from a job that we had finished
and so I sat down with my wife and I
told her I said listen I said I can take
this money I can catch us up on a few
bills and I can go ahead and put all of
this in my name and give the business a
shot and on just under me
um or I can put it all in the bank and
um and I can go back to working for the
man
um and we thought on it we prayed on it
um but unfortunately there wasn't a
whole lot of time and she supported me
um trying it and it's and it's been a
good run
um but just not good enough and it's to
the point now where the bank accounts
are getting a little bit lower than we
both would like and um so I I've
accepted defeat for now
um and I'll go back and and work for the
man I'm just trying to figure out what
would be best I have tried to get wise
counsel from my family and half of them
say you know go and and work for a
government company because the benefits
are great uh your wife is pregnant and
that's not the only kid that you all
plan on having and then some of uh my
other family and friends they say man go
back for where the money's at it'll help
you bounce back quicker and I've
listened to you all for about a year or
so now and I have the complete Money
Makeover I have the baby step
Millionaires and I know that
um I can have retirement
um later on in life through other ways
than a government agency however I never
really paid much attention to the
benefit side of it before Marty the way
you're talking it sounds like you're
just defeated you're beat down you're
you're gonna make this move from a place
of fear and weakness if you're not
careful and I want you to do it from a
place of strength and so I want you to
stop talking that way about yourself
about the idea of work it sounds like ah
man I gotta go work for the man down at
like I want you to find something you
love to do and naturally you're going to
get paid well if you're good at that and
it's not an either or in my mind of do I
do it for the benefits of the pay the
private sector can provide both we've
got great benefits here may not be the
same as the government benefits but you
can create your own benefits when you
get paid you know 30 percent more it's
less of a feature at that point so I
don't want you to weigh this Apples to
Apples I want you to look at this whole
thing differently you've boxed yourself
into a corner where there where the
wisdom you've received is it's either
this or it's either this and it's George
either one sucks it's just not true and
I I do want to to man take what George
said and just Mash on it
I could go home every day and be like I
gotta work for the man the man is Dave
and he just takes it all out of me or I
could say dude I get to learn how to
play guitar from Eddie Van Halen I get
to sit by one of the goats of radio and
learn how this thing works and learn how
he runs a business and have access to
all these different opportunities and
get to be with some great editors and I
write a book and I I get to all of that
is perspective and I'm doing the same
job every day and so you can say I gotta
go back to work for the man or dude I I
got in the ring and I took like man my
partner passed away my I tried it on my
own I didn't make it I'm gonna go back
and retool I'm gonna learn some new
skills I'm gonna get back in the game
see what the young kids are doing these
days I'm gonna get back in and somebody
else is gonna pay me to learn how to do
this I'm gonna work really hard for them
you see the the difference in the
attitude my whole my whole voice changes
when I talk like that see what I'm
saying absolutely I do
um my thing is is I know that
um I know the business can do well
um I I know it can my grandfather told
me that I was
backed into a corner
um from when I tried to take it over
after my buddy passed he said I was
already in the hole and I did a fine job
so it's not really defeat but my my fear
is if I go after a state job that you
have to be in there for a certain amount
of time in order to reap the benefits of
those benefits and but what I'd really
like to do is I'd really like to go back
to work for a company for maybe five or
ten years until my wife and I are out of
debt with the mortgage
and I saved up my emergency fund again I
saved up a cushion for the business I
bought a few more tools that way I could
try this hey Marty's Adventure again
yeah why are you calling us you know
what you're gonna do go do it
go do it
okay listen you got hit in the mouth
real hard
you lost a friend you lost a CO like a
like a business partner man
you got a lot of transition so it's it's
natural to doubt yourself and then be
unsure of The Next Step but the way you
just laid this out man you know exactly
what you want to do
you know exactly what you stop asking
people for wisdom you've asked a
thousand people hey man what do you
think about you know you know what's
right for you and your family go get it
man Marty we're gonna give you one more
tool in the tool belt there and that is
Ken Coleman's get clear assessment as
well as his best-selling book from
paycheck to purpose I think that's going
to help you really figure out what that
next thing is so hang on the line Austin
will get you both of those resources and
we're wishing you the best man thanks so
much for the call